[Music]
John wick chapter three Parabellum so
John Luke chapter three is you guessed
at the third film in the John wick
series feel like John wick started out
as this pure thing this guy's wife died
and then the dog she left him was killed
they just went apeshit on these people
killed his dog but where the possibility
and opportunity of franchise can be seen
by a studio well a franchise there will
be so now is the John wick trilogy at
the end of John wick chapter two
spoilers for John wick Chapter two it
leaves off John wick is on the run and
in this movie yes he's still on the run
and now assassins are coming after him
what I like about this movie other than
the badass rate and the action sequences
or I guess I'll start out with that the
action scenes in this smooth movie holy
[ __ ] I mean I shouldn't be surprised at
this point it's pretty much what you've
come to expect from a John wick movie it
just never ceases to amaze and at a
point where it's just like all right
they're just on God mode at this point
John wick is just untouchable and he's
just perfect they throw in something
worse like god John wick has to use more
tactics now think about his fighting
technique also that I just noticed and I
appreciate there's a scene in particular
where a couple guys have knives and
they're coming after John wick and
they're kicking at John wick and you can
just tell he takes the kicks so he can
block the knives it's just like there's
not enough time to block the kick and
the knives so he's just like alright I
guess I'm gonna take the kicks to the
chest to try it off being I'll be able
to block the knives I just I like [ __ ]
like that it also keeps John wick from
being untouchable because he is in fact
taking damage that said it's chip damage
who are we kidding
the dude is God but even the first fight
that happens with John Blake it just it
sets the stage just like everyone around
me Luke Oh same kind of style flash and
fulfillment you get from a mortal combat
fatality even the dogs are [ __ ]
badass in this movie there's someone in
here it has a couple of dogs the dogs
take part in the action sequences it's
like the dogs are out for revenge for
the original dog not all dogs go to
heaven that's a [ __ ] lie they do and
the thing I appreciated that kind of I
found jarring in John wick chapter two
that I've now fallen into and appreciate
and accept in John wick chapter 3 is the
world-building this is a very eccentric
world that they keep building on it's
very comic-book ass I'm in let's face it
John wick is on the run and fighting
essentially super assassin Illuminati
come on did the logic
but it's cool it's not real or is it I
will say the main lady who's essentially
the spokesman for this super assassin
Illuminati this lady was kind of wooden
I get why she was cast because it's like
she could be a voice actor she has
something about her voice where she
enunciates every word like this came
across is kind of wooden but I love the
fact that I would say John wick has
fallen into what it is but it never
didn't fall into what it is it's always
falling into what it is it's always
lived up what it is it just doubles down
or triples down now there's even a
matrix reference or two in this movie
beyond the fact that Laurence Fishburne
and Keanu Reeves are in the same movie
together but really it's in here so you
need good because in the end John wick
chapter 3 delivers what you want in a
John wick movie and the John wick
trilogy now delivers what we wanted from
the taken trilogy to is my least
favorite but still cool three is better
than two but not as good as one but if
you're a fan of the John wick movies
you're gonna love this that'll say John
wick chapter three is worth watching and
worth buying on blu-ray
all right so John wick Chapter three
have you seen it what did you think of
it and alright the hand-to-hand combat
was who could beat John wick in a fight
don't give me the [ __ ] like shanks soon
could just steal a soul mid-fight or
Vader could choke him out from like 30
feet away kind of stuff I'm talking like
real hand hand fighter who could beat
John wick in a fight whoever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]